poland is one of the most
um you know radical proponents of
crushing sanctions
uh the quicker the better the more
the harsher the better and this is our
stance from the very beginning we are
not doing this because not only it's not
only our moral duty but it's also the
war for
uh preserving the war to
actually um
you know defeat
the empire of evil the defeat empire of
lies
russia
and we have to be as united and as
strong as it gets can the world ever be
safe while president putin holds power
in russia
if
uh europe and the free world uh loses
this battle loses this war
we are not going to be safe uh any
longer because we will always be under
threat and blackmail from putin
we would like him to be totally removed
of course but but he represents a brutal
power he russia is a superpower and if
uh at the end of the day
ukraine survives as a sovereign state
which is our sole objective and this is
why we are supporting
ukraine through all sorts of different
means
um then this is our victory how much
risk do you think there is at the moment
of this war spreading outside of ukraine
well like we do have fears about
putin attacking moldova
i don't think he would they're attacking
a nato country
this is why probably also our
scandinavian neighbors want to join nato
as quickly as possible and we do
everything possible to support them in
on this way
and if you were to give a direct message
to president putin today what would it
be
stop this war
russia has to stop this war
immediately because it's it's it's so
cruel it's so
barbarian that it's very very difficult
to imagine